[Music]
with Red Dead Redemption - Rockstar
Games has set out to create its most
ambitious open-world experience to date
it is an epic tale of outlaw life that
seamlessly blends story with action
let's go
click an exploration with choice all
under the constant threat of danger the
world is full of adventures and
experiences that you discover naturally
as you move fluidly from one moment to
another
gentlemen we'll all know what to do
Arthur can undertake a wide array of
nefarious activities with his fellow
gang members some are large scale
heights while others are more personal
you can rob a train passerby or a coach
holed up a store pergola house or go
loan-sharking here for money or you can
simply go off and explore alone if
you're feeling brave enough the
countryside towns and frontier are full
of rival gangs and outlaws each
different but all of them deadly how's
that score you stole offers rich one in
this rapidly civilizing world lawmen are
cunning weather tracking known outlaws
or investigating a crime scene now I'm
not a failure to pass a quick judgment
and I know you don't hire a saint to
catch a sinner get a price on your head
and bounty hunters will track you down
Arthur must always be prepared to defend
himself against whatever is thrown at
them the Deadeye system has been
expanded and will progress in stages
allowing you to slow time paint targets
and seek critical or fatal points of
your enemies how and when you use it is
up to you your experience is defined by
the choices and decisions you make for
Arthur you can of course choose what to
wear ride eat and which guns to carry
shave bathe or don't it's up to you Red
Dead Redemption too is bold of things to
do
[Music]
there are countless secrets to uncover
there and people to meet you can get
into raucous altercations take in a show
chase down bounties fight a duel and a
lot more be careful out there
is the country your behavior has
consequences and people will remember
you and your actions you can also
experience the game in first-person or
taking the world with new cinematic
cameras for some stunning views
the result is a world that is deep
teeming with life and very menacing its
constellation
[Music]